the opening scene introduces us to a guy
named Yoon xiok Wu who serves as a lab
worker in the military during a few days
of leave he returns home only to find
that his family members are planning to
go on a holiday trip overseas despite
his strong desire to join them on the
trip he is unable to go as his military
service is not over yet apart from this
xiaku's family does not hold his
profession in high regard and as a
result they do not appear to be happy on
his arrival during their brief
conversation his mother makes a mean
remark noting that she sometimes forgets
that he is in the military because his
duties do not align with the typical
image of a soldier here it is revealed
that siakwu has been working in the
military research lab for his two-year
service which is why his family does not
give much importance to his work now
that siakwu will be staying alone at
home his father sternly warns him not to
tamper with his Liquor Cabinet while his
mother hands him a note with a list of
household chores he must complete before
they return the first work on the list
is to clean the house and take out the
trash siakwu despite his reservations is
left with no show
follow these instructions as his family
departs on their vacation siakwu begins
cleaning the house he gathers the
recyclable trash and disposes of it in a
designated area located right in front
of the apartment Upon returning home he
receives a voicemail from his female
friend Kim Yoo Min who invites him to
join her for dinner later in the evening
xiaokwoo gets excited to meet her which
prompts him to hasten his cleaning
efforts during this process he comes
across a decaying Apple that seems to
have been infected from one side a few
moments later he is also startled when
he opens a bucket filled with putrid
food waste reluctantly he transfers the
foul smelling food into a trash bag and
proceeds to clean the bucket as well
after cleaning the entire house siakwu
gets ready for dinner and heads out with
a trash bag in hand along the way he
comes across a food waste disposal bin
so he throws his trash bag containing
the rotten apple right into it
unbeknownst to anyone all of that rotten
waste food undergoes some sort of
chemical reaction which results in the
generation of something big and
unexpected affected later that evening
the sanitation workers arrive in their
truck to collect the waste which is
later subjected to processing and
ultimately converted into cattle feed
for the livestock of different Farms
following the process those livestock
are eventually slaughtered for their
meat which finds its way onto restaurant
plates for customers on the other hand
xiak Wu meets up with you men at a
restaurant where they relish a
delectable barbecue meal they also
decide to try a special dish of the
restaurant which is cow's liver while
eating cioc Wu feels something in his
mouth he takes it out only to discover a
peel of the same rotten apple he had
disposed of earlier although the
coincidence is very eerie he does not
pay much attention to it and continues
to savor the food without any hesitation
he is completely unaware of the fact
that the meat originates from the same
cows that were fed with tainted food
waste in the midst of all this human
takes some pictures of the delicious
food via cell phone curious siakwu asks
her for the reason why she's doing that
to which she replies that she wants to
capture each and every moment of her
life so that she can cherish them in the
few future and also toss them up on the
gram for seven likes after their meal
xiakwu and yumin go to an empty Park
where they share a passionate kiss
xiaokwoo gets Carried Away by emotions
prompting him to make physical advances
this makes you men feel uncomfortable so
she stops him xiakwu then invites her to
his place so that they can have some
private time together but the latter
hesitates pointing out that they have
only known each other for three days and
that they should go slow believing that
he offended her siaku apologizes to her
and confesses his feelings towards her
he says that he loves her a lot and
wants to marry her this leaves humans
speechless for a moment after this
tsiaku inquires why someone as
attractive as human would be interested
in an unromantic guy like himself in
response you men tells him that she
finds him very kind and loyal qualities
she values greatly this sets him apart
from other guys in her eyes as the two
continue chatting you men suddenly
notices an unusual and peculiar black
mark on siaku's face before they can
talk about it their conversation is
rudely disrupted by a couple of high
school students who throw a ball toward
enraged he chastises the students and
instructs them to go home however the
students band together and start beating
him up shiakwu was eventually knocked to
the ground leading him to vomit a piece
of the meat he consumed earlier the next
second something very strange happens
siak Wu undergoes a sudden
transformation into a zombie-like
creature endowed with increased strength
he surprisingly overpowers the students
and even resorts to biting them with his
sharp teeth human captures siaku's
shocking transformation and his violent
behavior on her phone before fleeing the
scene out of fear xi'aku tries to stop
her desperately insisting that he is not
the person she had just witnessed but
his pleas fall on deaf ears following
this it's yakwu with a confused face
also departs the park wondering how it
all happened in the aftermath of this
event the two students also get infected
through siaku's bite and slowly undergo
a transformation as well changing them
into zombies they then approach a young
couple in the park and launch an
aggressive attack on them in the
meantime you human boards a bus in order
to head back home but her health seems
to be deteriorating as well she begins
to cough uncontrollably and feels
increasingly Restless her face also
starts to exhibit the same black mark
exactly as siok Wu a short while later
she abruptly gets off the bus and throws
up on the side of the road gradually all
of those people who had their beef meal
earlier are seen vomiting in the streets
they also begin to show aggressive
behavior due to the virus as a result
they turn upon one another engaging in
brutal altercations for no apparent
reason elsewhere ciak Wu reaches out to
one of his friends and goes to meet at a
bar in a bid to find an explanation as
to what's going on siakwu tries to
confide in his friend however the latter
fails to grasp his actual problem
believing that siakwu is simply stressed
his friend suggests that they hit the
dance floor and attempt to divert his
troubled mind however the loud music and
crowded environment deeply disturbs Yak
will this results in his getting into a
brawl with the other party goers during
this commotion siakwu bites several of
them causing them to be exposed to the
infection he then makes his way back
home during which he accidentally drops
his phone on the road due to this you
Min is unable to reach him as the virus
continues its unrelenting spread
throughout the city it plunges the area
into great chaos news outlets begin
reporting on the virus describing the
peculiar and distressing symptoms
exhibited by infected individuals such
as alterations and eye appearance rabid
outbursts and heightened strength in an
attempt to control the situation the
Department of Agriculture takes decisive
action employing over 30 Health
officials to conduct thorough
inspections of local livestock farms and
once the examination is done they
suspect that six of these Farms have
been contaminated by now a week passes
and siak Wu who is now completely
transformed into a zombie is seen in his
apartment watching the news in a state
of profound agitation his frequent
outbursts appear to have led to the
destruction of items in his Apartments
rendering it in a state of disarray a
few days later his family returns from
the holiday trip and rings the doorbell
of the apartment when they receive no
response from xiaokwoo they use a spare
key to access the apartments inside they
witnessed the house in a completely
messed up and wrecked State his father
is specifically Furious to see his
cherished liquor bottles shattered into
pieces moments later they find xiaok Wu
sitting still in darkness as they call
out to him he starts advancing towards
them in an unusual way witnessing this
the family members sent something amiss
but before they can react siakwu
launches an attack on his parents and
bites them to death amid this horrifying
event his sister manages to run into the
bathroom and lock herself in a few more
days pass by and the virus seems to have
taken on a new form the infected people
are now exhibiting additional symptoms
like an uncontrollable appetite for
sexual desire and profound depression
they have now transformed into
aggressive entities as they wildly
attack those who remain uninfected as a
result of this the number of casualties
is rapidly escalating and the situation
is spiraled into an uncontrollable
nightmare in an attempt to stop the
epidemic the government issues an
advisory they urge the citizens to seek
safety and prescribe a course of action
that includes running away from people
exhibiting strange Behavior incredibly
no one had thought of that yet however
it is not that simple as the city is
already under the Dominion of the
infected the uninfected people are seen
on the rooftops of buildings shouting
for help on the other hand the
scientific and medical community are
still unable to find out the origin or
potential remedy for this Insidious
virus the next scene unfolds on the Grim
streets of the city where a number of
zombies are seen roaming around it is at
this moment when siak Wu meets you men
once again they appear to recognize each
other and start to walk together shortly
after they stumble into a decaying Apple
lying on the ground you men picks it up
and offers it to xiaok Wu who takes a
bite out of it without thinking
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching